[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's john smoltz the uh
emmy award-winning outstanding uh
sports event analyst and well let me you
know before we get to all of that i'm
watching
the golf tournament this weekend
american century
and my boy john smoltz is leading and i
thought well that's great
john's going to win and then he's going
to go you know he's going to be
hosting the all-star game and then you
lose to vinnie del negro
how nervous were you pitched in a world
series before john
how nervous were you compared to how you
were on sunday in the
last couple of holes there so it wasn't
the nerves
that got me i mean i felt great
in a baseball game of course golf is
different story so
and it you know in some of the
tournaments that i played in the nerves
were worse
in golf unfortunately in this tournament
i
uh i had lost my swing so
there's it's a worse scenario than
nerves like it isn't the nerves that
lost my swing i just lost the
fundamentals of my swing and when you do
that in golf you're like hanging on
and so i felt like there was nowhere to
go like in baseball if i lost my
fastball i had my slider i had my split
or vice versa
and golf if you lose your swing you're
basically
you're you're uh you're trying to figure
out how you're going to get the ball in
the hole so i
i i definitely was uh battling the last
round i wish i would have had
a better uh a better swing going but i
got to give benny all the credit because
he played great that last night that
last day and then you know the story
about
him losing his dad and not telling
anybody and and winning the tournament
was something
pretty incredible you needed leo mazzoni
i think to help you out there
come come out to the mound and uh and
but but explain
how you lose your swing well you know in
golf like i'm not connected
mechanically like i was in baseball yeah
you get a reminder in baseball and come
out and say hey do this
and greg olson my caddy was great and
trying to get me through the round but i
but in golf like i don't have i'm not as
technically sound i mean i'm kind of a
self-taught golfer anyways and when you
hit a ball
i think it was around 11th hole and you
go where did that come from
all of a sudden you start thinking about
things that you don't have a go-to shot
and so
i'll i will have learned another lesson
a painful lesson about
you know finishing the deal because the
shot on 17 is the whole tournament for
me and i
i hit a bad shot on 17 but it wasn't
because i can honestly say
in past tournaments it would be more
nerves but now i played in enough
tournaments that the nerves
aren't the issue as much as me not
making a good swing
but what's tougher hitting a baseball or
you know hitting
hitting a golf ball hitting a golf ball
under the circumstances of a tournament
you know
especially when you know that you got a
chance to win
a tournament which you know i've only
won a couple so
hitting a golf ball under self-induced
pressure i would guess
would be the the thing because it's not
moving you would think hitting a
baseball is way tougher yeah
and the art of hitting a baseball
certainly is tougher
because anybody can hit a golf ball but
it's can you hit a golf ball straight or
can you hit a golf ball with that
tension that
you know you can't have tension you can
you can have a little tension and hit a
baseball and be a little aggressive
um you can't really do that as a as a
golfer
john will be on the call with joe buck
the fifth consecutive all-star game that
they've been together that'll be at
eight eastern
on fox pre-game coverage beginning at
seven
eastern kenny rosenthal tom verducci
will also be there
as well we've been talking about the
home run derby
uh a lot of people probably tuned in
because ohtani was there even though he
bowed out
in the first round i was looking for a
comp here john
of maybe somebody you played against or
with who could have
done both pitching and hitting i don't
know
carlos zambrano was a great hitting
pitcher
good pitcher uh madison bumgardner
uh mike mussina do you know anybody
that back then that could have been able
to pull this off of what
not have the power of ohtani but to be
able to be a com
a day-to-day hitter not really um
you know the pitchers like mike hampton
the pitchers you just mentioned
they they had ability to you know
run two three four homers in a year
maybe um
but no nobody to this magnitude that
we've been able to see
do it at a lot a level that is unmatched
you know and go back to babe ruth i know
babe ruth
it's it's easy to just make that
comparison but it's harder to try and
draw out what babe ruth did to what
ohtani's doing
in this era because there's so many more
home runs and i think ohtani in itself
i've said this many times and i know a
lot of people think i've
lost my mind when i say it if he just
pitched
if all he did was pitch he would be
making the trails of one of the best
pitchers in our game
period but he doesn't just pitch he
doesn't have the reps he's only got like
25 26 starts
and he's at such a high level
offensively people don't understand
you've got to concentrate and share your
energy
in places that pitchers just can't do on
a daily basis you can't pitch once every
five days
and rake like he does every four days
and then
share that that greatness you're gonna
give up
something and he's giving up something
on the pitching end no doubt
because he's been so good offensively
and i say that if he didn't take another
at back
and he just pitched the second half
hands down mvp
i mean hands down we thought if he had
these numbers at the end of the year
that would be a great year ending
statistics
so i'm in awe of what he's doing because
i know as a pitcher how much of time i
dedicated to my craft
he's not dedicating that time he's not
giving himself
and rightfully so because he's a two-way
player so
to give you a perspective and i'll say
it tonight on the broadcast
when you get ready to pitch on the road
okay forget the all-star game
which is what he's doing you time your
your your performance to get ready so
that maybe five minutes before your team
ends up
making the last out you go out to the
mound to pitch he can't do that
he's got a time at 20 20 minutes or so
before
then he's got to go hit then his team
hits then he goes on the mound
he might be 30 minutes before he
actually throws his first pitch
in a game as a pitcher so there's so
many hurdles that he's overcoming and
making it look pretty easy
um you know it's it's amazing to watch i
just wonder about the whole mental
preparation because as a hitter
you have to prepare for the picture
you're facing and as a pitcher
you have to prepare for an entire lineup
and to do that on the same day
it'd be like playing safety and
quarterback in the same game
yes i mean the biggest thing is the
physical act can be done
the mental awareness and and you get
more tired
like you could see him being more
exhausted in those games rightfully so
because he's sharing the information
both ways he wants to get hits
and then he wants to go and and pour his
energy in when you're pitching
when you pitch in the national league or
american lake especially in a national
league it's not like he's playing
national league rules when he hits
he pitches you're p you're hitting ninth
you really don't care about hitting
you you're going to put a bunt down
there's no stress i mean you're only
thinking about the eight or nine hitters
you've got to get out
so he's he's got a combo of leading off
or batting second and getting right away
in a different mindset
before he even gets in the pitching
mindset so it's a unique uh skill set
and
and i don't know how it's interesting
what joe madden is going to be able to
do because they need his back
i don't know if you can keep leading him
off and still pitch
uh at the rate that he's doing maybe
drop him in the order i don't know but
this is going to be pretty fun to watch
how would you pitch him definitely
splits away i mean
anything going away because anything
coming in i've seen him take high
fastball sliders at the back foot
um the one game that he struggled a
little bit offensively gaussman pitched
against him really well and he's got a
great split
and you know that game he looked a
little bit tired from the standpoint of
trying to do both and he pitched an
outstanding game against the giants
so i would have to make sure that i
would have to get something going away
from him because his play coverage and
strength is too good right now
and he's such a great athlete i think
that people don't realize his size
his speed and then he's got an
incredible right arm
and he's the best power hitter in the
game
i guess yeah it's it's unique the only
comp i can give you is like a
bo jackson who played two different
sports in the same kind of spot
of size speed but he played two
different sports this guy's playing two
different sports in the same sport
because we've never seen anybody do it
right and leon sanders would be another
guy that
would come up to mind because
athletically to do what they're doing
is something no one could ever envision
um
a guy especially at this level in our
game at the all-star break
30-some home runs is incredible we have
joe madden otani's manager on tomorrow
if he asked your advice on how long do
you do you stay with this
how long do you do you want him to go
you know
two ways here what would you say well
if the contract didn't state that he's
got to keep doing it it would be one of
those things that i would
wait it does state that well i would
think part of the reason he's with the
angels is the contract that they worked
out that he was going to get a chance to
do this for however many years i don't
know what that means or what it says but
i think that any anybody who
tried to get out in front of this
thought that one of the areas would
phase out
but do you think that there are teams
that wouldn't they weren't going to give
him this opportunity to do both
i think there were teams that were
probably hesitant in the beginning
to try to you know navigate this because
his feet to the fire were quick
and i think all of us who got out in
front of us said this isn't going to
work
like he needs to have some time here or
time there
and he's proven everybody wrong and
really the angels i i gotta give him
credit because they stuck with it
what my advice would be if the angels
got to a place
this is the this is the rub of what what
is ohtani's greatest asset to the angels
well right now everyone would go was
obviously a city
but if they get to the playoffs this
greatest asset is this pitching
they don't have that kind of pitching so
that would be a challenge when you get
closer
to let's say they were in a playoff run
how do you get him ready to pitch game
one
and sacrifice something maybe from his
hitting standpoint to know he's so
important to win a game on the mound how
many games can he win in a series
obviously at the plate so it's a it's a
delicate challenge but i'll tell you joe
madden has
has uh a good plan and he's worked it
out we're talking to the hall of famer
john smoltz he'll be with joe buck
tonight eight eastern on fox pre-game
coverage starts at seven
kenny rosenthal and tom verducci will be
on the field
as well part of the broadcasting crew
the uh
spider tac uh controversy has kind of
gone away for a little while i
i kind of liken it to you know a police
officer
is here so you don't speed by him
you wait until you're past him and then
you may speed by him so i'm assuming
pitchers are just putting it away to
bring it back as a
former pitcher john what would you be
doing if you were using it
well i think the biggest thing is uh
that the information that's come out and
the timing that they gave the pitchers
you should be able to know how to pitch
without it
especially in the summer and i think
every pitcher that's an elite pitcher
will learn how to get around that aspect
of okay this probably went too far
and the rosin and sweat and the
ability to go to your mouth and create
some saliva is there for the pitcher
now the challenge will be of course is
going to be if it gets cold out
you know in the at the end of the year
but i think
once they understand um that they don't
have to have
you know it's kind of like a
psychological thing that in the summer
you don't really need
you're going to see pitchers return back
to the elite pitchers will return back
to their form
because it won't be this rhetoric or
conversation we're having because
they need this to pitch now it might
hurt some fringe pitchers
or some pitchers who have been able to
excel because of it
they're going to have to learn
differently and that's where you're
going to see the offense balance be a
little bit better
and i think that's what you've seen with
hitters being a little more confident
that they're not seeing the kind of
revolutions
and rpms that they were before when you
doctored the baseball how did you do it
john
when i doctored it yeah i wish i could
have doctored the baseball
the the bullfrog was the only way with
rosin
you know that's the one area where if
baseball next year can get to a common
ground to wherever
i think they're working on a substance
that will work for everybody because no
hitter wants to know that a pitcher
doesn't have control over baseball see
it went from being able to control the
baseball to be able to do things to a
baseball that haven't been done before
you know and i think that's the balance
that's the argument and
hitters will not complain if you have
control of the baseball
where they think it takes it to the next
level is when the backspin and the spin
rate
gets to an all-time high and i think
that's where they say okay that's
crossing the line
so back in the day when we couldn't go
to our mouth
so you're pitching in colorado with some
of my worst feelings in the world or i
pitched in cleveland
i had no way of getting grip on the
baseball and my sup my
performance suffered it really did and
so from the
from the moment it got below 40 i was in
trouble
but anything that was over that we had
the rosin and we had the ability and
and the the bullfrog by the way only
lasts
if you have a short inning because
there's nowhere to put it i don't i
didn't i didn't have anything on my body
it would basically be a little dab
before the inning would start go right
to the rosin and then i could pitch but
if i had a 30 pitch inning
then it was there was nothing to go to
so i think you're going to see a balance
come back after the season's over of
technology being able to
or baseball being able to come together
and have something that works for
everybody
i'll leave you with this the all-star
that isn't a household name
but we should keep an eye on tonight wow
good question
um
i mean i i'm fans of guys that when you
bring that up
i think of whit maryfield from the
kansas city royals
on how he does his thing when it isn't
the most popular thing right he's not
hitting a ton of home runs eggs he just
gets base hits and steals
we're gonna start seeing more of that in
their game i think we're going to start
seeing the david fletchers we're going
to start seeing
guys who don't shine and he's 32
john he's 32 leading baseball in stolen
bases
and that's what i'm saying like the art
of the game is suffered in some ways
because of the strategy of the game
that's been playing we're going to start
seeing some outliers come back
and see more speed and see more
creativity because
you can't fill a roster with one-way
players and i think you're starting to
see the value
like i i don't know many people in the
country don't know who david fletcher is
but he signed a five-year deal the
angels love him he can't he'll hit a
ball above his head he'll hit a ball at
his ankles
it won't show up on any statistic that
is sexy
but yet all he does is get on base and
help his team and i think those are the
kind of guys that
when you look at the all-stars are
always going to take the big boys are
always going to take the headlines
but under the radar you're going to
start seeing these guys play the game a
little bit differently
everybody's going to watch ohtani but
i'm watching wit tonight instead
thank you there you go see i mean in
colorado
you know if he played in colorado he
would be pushing
the average way north of you know 300
and he would be stealing a lot more
bases because
the way the game is played in colorado
everyone assumes there'd be home runs
but there's gonna be more hits
can you later in the game tonight drop
in as uh you know joe as i said earlier
today on the dan patrick's show
because oh yeah i'll stay like if you
get to the sixth inning maybe like i'll
make sure my fans stay
sixth inning seventh inning just say you
know joe as i said earlier today on the
uh
the popular dan patrick show yeah
there's there's
you know i'm going to tie that in with
mary yeah
i love it you know there you got it so
whenever he comes
when he comes in the game and he comes
up to the plate tune
in prepare
i want fox to be ready for a blast
of popularity your ratings are going to
have a spike
when when whit comes to the plate
everybody's going to be tuning in
uh my best to joe and uh john uh good to
talk to you buddy
thank you for having me that's uh johnny
smoltz hall of famer
he won a sport he won a sports emmy